So recently
there have been some moms slamming me for talking about side hustles.
This is the debit card that I get paid on for my side hustle.
If your husband takes care of all your needs
and you are 100% focused on your kids all the time,
but you can do something small while they're asleep
or something that fills your cup or you're passionate about,
there is nothing wrong
with having a creative way to make a little side income.
All the fun things that I like
that I normally give up when we're budgeting,
like coffee, I use my side hustle money on.
I use my side hustle money to buy the giant pack of cloth diapers
that will get my infant until he's 2 years old.
We still don't go on vacations or do any crazy things.
And yes, we live within our means,
but like, if I wanna get my hair done every three months,
it's expensive. It's kind of a luxury.
So sometimes I tell my husband, like,
don't worry, I have some money on my debit card.
I will use that. Also,
nothing wrong with just being a stay at home mom
and not working at all or being focused on any side hustle.
You do what you need to do to make it work in your marriage,
in your parenting journey.
Don't let anyone judge you, mama,
for what you decide to do.
And yes, I'm talking
even to the women
who Have absolutely no way of staying home with their kids,
because it just is not feasible,
and they have to work to provide.
I'm talking to you, too.
Don't be ashamed. We're all doing the best we can.